hello everyone before diving into this
topic i've got to clarify something
i
am reading some of the pieces that i'm
producing and
that means that these are things that i
wrote
the reason i'm doing that rather than
speaking extemporaneously is because now
and then if i'm pushing myself to the
limits of my conceptual ability then i
have to choose my words with the undo
care that writing allows and i suppose
that has the disadvantage that's
associated with reading something rather
than speaking off the cuff but the
advantage of precision and care
so today i'm going to talk i'm going to
read a piece that i entitled why twitter
is insane
it is often said that social media is
driving us out of our minds individually
and collectively is this true
and if so
how and why
the eminent social psychologist jonathan
height recently wrote a hard-hitting
article showing that use of certain
forms of social media particularly by
girls just entering adolescence was
directly and causally associated with
higher rates of depression and
depression-related symptoms since the
early to mid 2010s
i had been thinking
along broadly similar lines particularly
with regard to twitter
and how its incentives are structured
compared to those that characterize
healthy human interactions
the extent of its harmful pathology has
recently been brought home to me as a
consequence
of those deliberations
a thought experiment
imagine for example that you learned a
particular pattern of communication in
your family one that when used on others
triggered a passive or even outright
aggressive resistance
by definition
the unusual method of communication you
had been taught
one that did not generalize well to the
broader social environment
would characterize you at least as far
as society is concerned
as insane
now let's ask how does twitter
like that family differ from the real
world in how it requires us to
communicate with each other
how does it make us too
insane
the first way
is in the manner in which it bypasses
the traditional means
for measuring the quality of
communication
in the real world
high volume communication is extremely
costly requiring both hard to establish
credibility why otherwise would large
numbers of people want to read or listen
to you
and access to the wealth necessary for
such communication either directly
through personal accumulation or by
proxy such as a contractual arrangement
with a publishing house
twitter casts these
limitations asunder
the consequence of this demolition of
potentially vital regulation
is multiplied by the fact that twitter
provides universal access to each of its
users hard-won
personal networks
the second way
is how anyone regardless of competence
or social status can comment to anyone
else's entire network of followers
merely by commenting on something the
latter posted
that same commenter therefore can access
all those who have chosen to follow not
them
but the target of their say
insult and derision without having
demonstrated any of the competence
necessary to have attracted such
attention
on their own
this
democratization
of communication enables a parasitism
completely divorced from competence it
massively inflates noise relative to
signal bypassing all the screening
mechanisms that have been so
painstakingly developed to shield us
from incessant racket in the real world
the third way twitter breaks the norms
of standard human interaction is the
zero cost and even potential benefit it
imposes on those who engage in flagrant
ethical misconduct
it facilitates the implied moral
elevation
that accrues
to the accuser who adopts the position
of virtuous judge merely by formulating
an accusation however vague ill-founded
and scurrilous
in the same vein
there is no cost for insults
ad hominem attacks
and provocative statements
incitement in other words people can
hide behind their anonymity
as well and act if possible even more
brazenly
too often therefore
the median stimulates
a reactive rage
as it denies even to competent users two
of the main privileges traditionally
granted to them
the presumption of innocence and the
right and ability to engage in effective
self-defense
the mob
can say anything at all about you or
your thoughts online despite your
hard-earned reputation
and there is nothing you can do about it
any member of what can far too easily
become a mob can level any accusation no
matter how slanderous against anyone at
all for any reason
and there is little or nothing that the
target can do in response
perhaps most worrisome of all
is the fact that this incited rage
bleeds over
into the real world
all the impotent anger generated is
externalized away from the social
network
and dispersed
thus the ambient emotional temperature
of general society is raised
degree by degree
to the boiling point
malignant narcissism
we know this instinctively but it would
be easy to test an ambitious phd student
case one's listening could expose one
group to twitter for half an hour
another randomly established to another
social media network and a third if
desired to a reading task
all study participants could then be
assigned say a competitive aggression
research task
to determine if twitter exposure
heightens the proclivity to respond
in kind with punishment to provocation
i believe that twitter's reward
structure even more than facebook's
incentivizes malignant narcissism
it enables and benefits free riding and
prioritizes psychopathic motivation
and it garners disproportionate
attention in doing so capitalizing on
the attractiveness of outrageous
behavior while externalizing all the
associated and inevitable costs to the
innocent broader society
this
is the psychological equivalent
of the tragedy of the commons
the psychological equivalent to
pollution
of the air we all breathe
i recently spoke about all this to the
author of the article i mentioned
previously psychologist jonathan height
and on the same email string to stephen
pinker the eminent cognitive
psychologist
how did my psychologist colleagues react
height
noted that twitter indeed cuts the link
between quote competence or value
creation and prestige
slash reward
pinker likewise observed quote the
contrast between twitter and
face-to-face communication is profound i
have been astounded at how some of my
students and younger colleagues think
nothing of spitting utterly gratuitous
and unjustified snark at respected
figures in their fields
i have to remind them
that they may meet these figures at a
conference someday or that they might be
on their tenure or grant review
committees
the transition from meetings
to zoom in the past two years may have
exacerbated this
but i suspect the main enabler is the
sense that their reference group
is their twitter same age peers and that
they don't have cues reminding them
they're part of a multi-generational
community
pinker added
quote there also seems to be a dynamic
of weaponizing social justice so that as
our society legitimately expands rights
for black people women gay people and
transgender people
it simultaneously creates weapons for
sociocultural warfare handing aggressive
professionals
a moralistic cudgel with which they can
demonize their competitors
in this case destructive trolling could
also be a side effect of moral progress
note that this would be consistent with
the appeal of moralistic mobbing
among younger generations
in status competitions with their
seniors they are disadvantaged along
every dimension but one
claimed moral superiority
end quote
how much are our social media networks
these massively broad scale social
experiments conducted with radically
insufficient knowledge of the underlying
psychological dynamics
incentivizing narcissism
an idea that particularly appealed to dr
height and how much
is too much
here's an uncomfortable conclusion
it does not take that many free riders
or criminals or people who simply just
don't care and who would just as soon
see everything burn
to radically destabilize complex social
organizations
i spoke recently with the journalist
andy noel about the anarchist group
antifa for example
after being informed by some democrats i
was corresponding with that this group
antifa didn't really exist
i didn't know what they meant
until i asked andy how many truly active
antifa cells he thought existed in the
u.s
and how many active full-time equivalent
members each cell might have
he thought 40
cells
with 20 members each
that's
800
all that damage
from 800 anarchists
that's the pareto principle a small
number of agents in any organization or
its equivalent pull
all the weight
it's worth remembering
that one percent of the u.s population
accounts for two-thirds of all violent
crime
and that a minority of that one percent
are repeat offenders
exacerbating polarization
have we built
so-called
communication systems
that are capable of destabilizing our
entire society
height believes that it was the mere
introduction of the retweet and like
buttons that facilitated the tit-for-tat
sharing of emotionally triggering
content
particularly that capable of generating
outrage
if a tech innovation that small
can exacerbate polarization on a
societal scale
how much disruption can these
communication technologies taken as a
whole create
enough to bring us down
the mental health data certainly
indicate that a major toll has already
been taken on female adolescents
what about the rest of us
what about our social institutions
it seems clear that the potential
psychological and sociological harm
engendered by the increasingly
monopolistic communication enterprises
engaging our society are such that we
should at least consider a push
to conduct research on the matter
with an eye to conceptualizing designing
and improving social media sharing
platforms that aren't prima facie
insane
and contagiously so
we must do so before our new and in some
ways miraculous mass communication
systems
pollute
the social world
beyond
repair